[Music]
ricky this is it
[Applause]
that is one of the most memorable
moments from the six seasons and 180
episodes of i love lucy the
groundbreaking sitcom made its debut on
october 15 1951 70 years ago last night
right here on
cbs it was a major hit at the time and
went on to live in syndication and
streaming that continues to this day the
show had a huge impact on television and
also on a small town in upstate new york
jamie wax is here with more on that
jamie good morning good morning jeff
isn't it crazy 70 years i have two kids
in their 20s and that show still makes
them laugh really hard i think that is a
testament to its legacy we visited
lucy's hometown jamestown new york where
now both the comedy legend and the art
of comedy itself are being celebrated
of all the crazy things that you've done
in the fifteen years
you mean to say that you've been married
to her for 15 years yeah 15 years and
they call me superman
i love lucy considered by many to be the
greatest and most influential sitcom of
all time
starred lucille ball as lucy ricardo
the zany wife of cuban band leader ricky
ricardo played by her then real life
husband desi arnaz
the pioneering series is credited with
establishing the basic format for almost
every television sitcom that followed
even until today
and while the world still continues to
love lucy there's one small town that
takes that love to a whole new level
jamestown new york lucille ball's
birthplace and childhood home
jamestown new york is a fairly small
place with a population of just over 30
thousand but lucille ball's impact and
legacy has made it a major destination
for people who love lucy and love comedy
so why don't you join the thousands of
happy puppy people and get a great big
bottle of maya media benjamin
from giant murals depicting iconic
scenes from i love lucy to a museum
dedicated to all things lucy and desi to
the competing lucy statues in the
neighboring village of celeron and now
that list includes a vision lucy herself
had to turn her hometown into a
destination for the celebration of
comedy germs where did the sudden fear
of germs come from it's ridiculous and
it goes to ridiculous lengths in prisons
before they give you a lethal injection
they swab your arm with alcohol
the national comedy center a 50 million
dollar state of the art museum dedicated
to all things funny opened its doors
three years ago i mean so much to look
at the museum celebrates every genre of
comedy across all eras stand up sketch
improv television and movies
go ahead and choose some select some
comedians i'm going to pick richard
pryor tina fey how about that and even
includes some of comedy's most infamous
item
cases but i'm very excited about this
one the puffy shirt from seinfeld most
people are all right well let's go there
and now you can learn about the
connection between jack benny and
phyllis diller jack benny and milton
berle but the curators may be proudest
of the museum's technologically advanced
exhibits that immerse visitors in the
process of comedy creation
and carl reiner journey gunderson is the
comedy center's executive director as a
curator as an archivist how do you take
on such a serious task as trying to
represent the entire spectrum of comedy
in a museum but also
not make it too serious i knew from the
concept phase that even if we were
successful raising all of the money and
hiring the best museum and exhibit
designers in the world that if we didn't
get the authenticity of the comedic
voice and the comedy community right
that this would become the butt of a
joke i'm avoiding getting started
because it's hard to be funny now
you know you know why because
it's hard to be funny when everything's
going so great
comedian louis black is on the museum's
board of advisors it's more than a
museum i kind of call it the library of
congress of comedy it gave a historical
sense to the craft that is comedy it's
better than going to a you know
weepertorium gee let's go to a tragedy
museum that'll be really great for the
kids let's see the most horrifying
things of the 20th century so what
you've got here is a place where you
have a reaction to the most horrified
20th century it still deals with a lot
of this still deals with the same thing
but on a much lighter level the center
has been a hit with visitors and critics
alike recently named best new museum by
usa today
and while in many ways it's an homage to
lucy
lucy wanted it to be much more and much
more is what it's become
lucy's last public appearance was at the
academy awards the night the stars shine
and she did lucille ball died in 1989 at
the age of 77
long before the project became a reality
but the hometown tributes have continued
including the annual lucille ball comedy
festival a legacy of love and more
importantly
laughter how important was
the influence of lucille ball
to this town it was lucille ball herself
who said to the officials in jamestown
don't just celebrate me
don't just
facilitate people looking at my stuff in
glass cases make my hometown a
destination of comedy as an art form
california here i come
right back where i started
[Music]
and this is a cultural institution
that's changing a small town along the
lines of the national baseball museum
it's really a special place and somehow
it makes a very subjective thing very
personalized we all said we gotta go
yeah we gotta go but what's cool there
is you can pick out a character or a
show right yes and it'll show you all
the other people related i mean you saw
a little bit in the piece if you went
with your wife and your kids each of you
would go to a kiosk and pick your
favorite people and it would know where
you are in the museum and guide you to
those people but also everyone who was
part of their style and their legacy
it's an amazing attraction i i loved
every clip you showed was my favorite
and learning that on the set of i've
loved lucy the couch was i know ball
blitz black and white tv you wouldn't
know her hair was red the couch was
really new
the red hair we knew you would fit in
right here
it's true